what is development i mean we've been
developing software
for many many years
some of us for a couple some of us for
more and the industry itself a long long
time
now development as it says is is fun
i love it i hope you love it too
uh
in development of course there's many
different phases there's planning
uh you know analysis so yeah we can take
our headphones off for that
development uh you know the most fun
part i would say and then of course some
fun there with testing and integration
i'm sure you've had your fun
uh with quality assurance quality
engineering uh different things happen
and different four stories come out so
it's it's an interesting exciting time
and of course deployment now in our talk
of course what i want to focus on is
development
what does
what do we have for for java developers
in store what can java developers as of
today
do
in their development how can they be a
faster how can it be made more simpler
easier what kind of those features that
makes it more development productive so
let's let's take a look at that later
today
um
of course i mean
when we talk about development
all of you must have had different
experiences like i said i was doing awt
back in the days i was doing you know
automation with uh
with unix and linux systems etc uh and
of course doing java development which
was going through cross platforms like
deployed many many different platforms
and operating systems across the world
so when that happens i mean
all of us come through and come from
different backgrounds and are working on
these different platforms
um you might be doing microservices you
might be doing serverless applications
on one of the cloud providers or on
kubernetes
you also might be doing event driven
applications and of course in some cases
you might be doing
applications in a traditional old way so
java as of today
runs almost anywhere right and all of
these different kind of
environments and
architecture patterns
need
need us to create
those different patterns and
applications uh in a more easy and
simplified manner and how does java
uh help us with that today uh of course
there are many different tools out there
to work with
you know you could look at
development kits which are provided by
cloud providers for example to integrate
there but then again what you're really
looking at is how can i be productive
how can i have the same experience that
i do on my local machine uh being able
to connect to environments like
kubernetes uh and open shift as an
example uh do the same microservices
serverless event driven application
development as well in a simplified
experience so
that's what's happening today and and of
course all these um
different uh architecture patterns needs
different kinds of tools and libraries
as well
so
if you've been developing java for uh
for a long time
i mean there's no hidden truth about
this a couple of years back i think
prior to java 9 as well
there were issues with for example
containerizing java applications they
won't stay you know stay up for a long
time they use a lot of memory uh there's
a lot of
you know startup time
overload
you know uh overhead uh loading classes
like you know that you that you might
not actually need sometimes so
not a lot of them and most of them
basically we don't need so there's a lot
of memory over here
in compilation doing it you know at
start-up time etc um made java much much
much slower
and to start up with right but then
again if you if you even started you
might have even heard prior to java 9
that you know containers were crashing
uh you know boundaries etc those things
of course have been uh
have have longer long been fixed but
still i mean from a container
perspective java becomes a used to
become a memory hog so that's that's
that's the truth that was out there the
heap would get bigger and bigger um and
of course
that would create challenges now the
challenges of course are there because
java was created in a different context
of time
where we were looking at big machines
and and deploying a lot of applications
uh in there as well so if i just kind of
quickly go back what i was what i would
say is like you know uh with with a
multi-application server that would run
we would expect applications to run on
it and we don't expect it to
um to to to giant anytime soon and it
would run as the application life cycle
would be for months
whereas
in a microservices world in a serverless
world you're looking at you know days
and minutes and seconds of
application lifetime
and that of course challenges now
because java was created from from a
different context when it was done back
in that time so how does that change
today we're going to take a look at it
so our world of course is full of you
know different things we have legacy
applications you know traditional
applications that run with java
we want to go into microservices and of
course we want to go into
writing functions as well how do we do
that so
um okay so java has problems with
containers is java dead
funny enough if i try to search
something like that on google it gives
me like what is it 49 million hits or
something so
uh so but
it is it is not dead right there is
there's a lot of things that java can
still offer so what is quarkus what can
quarkis do to solve this problem i mean
simple quark is an elementary particle
us being the hardest thing in computer
science but you know that elementary
particle that small thing is what we are
looking at that is exactly
the kind of java we want to work with
because
come on if we are going to do
serverless functions we want them to run
quickly for a couple of seconds we want
them to die and then of course we also
might want them to scale and we do not
want to wait for that to scale we want
it to be fast efficient you know
whatever kind of library we use if we
want it to be quick
and does the work
so
of course quark is brings um
and this talk is about carcass so uh
with my bias of course
um
quark is
will run uh and with your microservices
i mean there are platforms or frameworks
that are out there already that do
um that could help you with
microservices however quarkus
is built in a way that it runs with a
very small memory footprint
and it can and it can start up very
quickly etc so it's it's a really good
fit for microservices and you can scale
it even further down and
and you can write functions in java as
well you no longer need to just write go
and change your language just because
you wanted to write functions and java
was slow enough you can now do that in
quarkx
with quarkus so we'll take a look at
that today as well
so
let's take a bit more detail right i
mean
what does corkus really do
corkus has
um you know it
works with withdrawal vm uh quarkus has
a jvm mode so there's a native mode
which is the gravia mode there's a jvm
mode which is which we can run let's say
with open jdk and then there's
traditional cloud native stack
applications as well right traditionally
how you would write your microservices
so this for example is a very very
simple example of a rest application
here you would see hey the traditional
stack just to print a hello world
endpoint uh takes about 136 megabytes um
of your memory uh if you look at the
quarkus and jvm it's 73 megabytes i can
trim that even further down
with growl and native to 12 megabytes
now of course these are different use
cases when it comes to native and jvm
but then with jvm even you see almost
half of the time is improved so there's
a lot of optimizations that corkus is
also doing
um
quarkus is you know supersonic it is
extremely fast as well uh to sub
milliseconds if i was to look at a
simple rest endpoint
doing
quarkus with quarkus native it's almost
like 0.016 of second but then again of
course if i do jvm it goes up to one
second only not four seconds or 5
seconds or 10 seconds it is it is it is
a much much more faster runtime so
imagine you want to bring up your
serverless function which is really
small
does a certain thing you know goes out
calls a specific api does some
processing and finishes it up you know
you're looking at some millisecond times
here so it's it's not extremely uh it's
not slow it's extremely fast uh you
could write your microservices with
qarcus um
uh let's say for example in jvm you can
make them run for even longer sessions
right so you don't have to
uh stop for example like in corkus
native which is more geared towards
serverless you know of course does not
have all the awesome uh garbage
collection algorithms that jvm would
usually have but then you could choose
jvm and even in jvm it's less than a
second that it starts up for example and
uses an extremely little time of
a little amount of memory
then of course
let's take a look at a rest plus credit
application
and in a rest
plus crud so simple you know create
update delete kind of application using
the database at the back end you're
looking at caucus native doing you know
again some millisecond startup times
whereas quarkx jvm goes a little bit
higher goes up to two seconds of course
there's database connections etc all of
that that comes into play but you know
quark is still has optimized runtime for
that on the jvm and with the cloud
native stack again that goes to its
double amount as well which goes up to
almost like 10 seconds so you're looking
at a runtime which is giving you
extremely small size
at the same time it's giving you some
extreme performance as well and and that
is what quercus brings to um to through
the java world so what is what is
quarkus sub supersonic subatomic java
as we say it is it's a kubernetes native
java stack uh kubernetes native it means
that it literally is geared for
for java to run on kubernetes for java
to run as serverless functions for java
to run as microservices and for java to
perform
in these environments just like any
other language and even better in many
cases and it's tailored for growl vm
and open jdk hotspot as well so it's not
just about that it
uses native uh graph vm functionality
but it also optimizes uh with open jdk
as well
so you can still run
like i said with uh with jvm mode and
you can still get optimizations in there
as well and again it's crafted with a
lot of uh awesome libraries as well like
for example if you were working with
integration cord with the camel you have
quarkus camel as well that you can use
to write all your routes and patents
that you're used to in your integration
you can do that too so quarkus has some
awesome libraries there and we're going
to take a look when we get to the demo
part as well so
this is how our world looks now i mean
it was a bit different a couple of
slides ago and it should be different
now now we have our java mascot
everywhere it's it's in our micro
services uh it's running some of our
legacy code and of course it's also
running um
the the functions now of course legacy
code or traditional application service
style applications uh that's not what
quark is fit for but quark is definitely
fit for micro services and serverless so
more on the right hand side than on the
hand side here so perfect awesome let's
um let's get into
our demo so we're going to switch my
screen here
give me a second
okay
so my environment hopefully uh you're
able to see this as well
um so what i'll do is that of course i
have a project already created which is
d2
um and you know i'm using intellij you
can choose any um
any tool you like so typically you could
just go in here say hey create me a new
module
and in your module you can say i want to
create a quercus module then select your
extensions etc etc so that's one way of
doing it it's it's part of the intellij
uh mod um plugins as well so you can you
can use that you could also go for
example
on to the browser
and
if you went to the browser
let's just do this
if you went on the browser
you could go on something like
code dot
kiss dot io
um and on coded carcass dot io uh you
could also select
uh whatever kind of extensions you want
you can search them
for example
select them and then of course you can
download that or or or push to github as
well so that's also kind of
kind of cool
that you could do that
i am not going to do that today i will
be working more on
using something called the cli so
quarkus has a cli which i have installed
of course
[Music]
and
what it does is it has a couple of let
me just
it has a couple of parameters you can
create your application
uh you know you can build it uh you can
add extensions etc so it's it's quite
user friendly in that sense and i'm
quite used to since i run on a linux
machine here i'm quite used to uh
running um quark is through cli as well
so i'll just say quark is
uh create
let's say d2 was working let's say d3
right so i create demo three here
um and it's gonna go
um and and create from code dot corker
start io it's gonna create an
application now simply of course i'm
using uh intellij so i'm just going to
say hey
you know just drag in this
this module
for me
and we're going to do that big three
okay finish
i can just do that here as well
oh
okay
did i just oops yes i'm a little sick
let's do it again
let's create quarkxp3
so i just had to change my directory so
now i have my
my demos just gonna do that again
um import my module
i was wondering why there was an extra
one there but okay never mind
um and maybe
just in case i want to delete this one
delete perfect
so just to keep things clean
um okay so i have uh d3 so let's go in
b3
and in d3 i have so i've created this
application you know through cli now i
could report his
extension list and it's going to tell me
which extensions like already exist so
it says quarkx rest easy always already
exists
i can say quark is dev and it's going to
start a local quark session for me to
start developing code so usually if you
were developing in java and you would be
you would run something
and then you would try to compile it
then run it again what quarkus does is
something called live coding so you can
see it says here uh live coding is
activated and my application is already
listening on localhost port
8080 so if i go on my
localhost here
i can see i have
my application already loaded
i also have my hello endpoint which is
just like the generated code that has
already been written
um and then of course i also have
something called
slash q slush dev which is basically
which we call the developer ui now this
is pretty awesome because now here i can
see all the different extensions that
cork is has that are loaded into my
current runtime uh that it actually uses
and also it shows me hey these are the
beans that are loaded in your
environment
uh you know these are the interceptors
etc and since it uses arc yeah here you
can see that arc is loaded um and and a
lot of other stuff right and then of
course the config editor as well it
shows me the
the configurations that i currently have
now this will of course change
if i actually also
added more extensions it should it
should typically change so we'll we'll
see how that works as well so let's go
back to our
uh localhost 8080 and we can see our
application is there perfect and here
you can access devio it gives us a bit
of group application you know etc etc uh
stuff like that so hello rest easy is
out there so let's do a simple thing
let's go back
and
change
um
the
intellij
uh in our intellij let's go back and
change our greeting resource so it says
hello rest easy
and let's let's just say hello
awesome and then we
just go here
click and here it's
live
reloaded everything so you're actually
coding on the fly doing the stuff um
in in quercus
as you go along
so we can just
keep on playing with this
and
keep on doing this and this will work
awesome so you can see it goes like that
but what about what about if i made a
mistake sometimes we all make mistakes
how does that work so it will throw an
error right away and not just
simply
the full stack trace of everything
that's going on but at the same time
also
showing that hey this is
a reverse stack so you can see that you
have a problem here you expected a
semicolon rather than going all the way
down you get a reverse stack you can see
that here
um
and you can also see it on your
um on your console so so let's
let's quickly take a take a look at our
browser as well so if i go on the
browser i do the same thing
and you will see that yes i have exactly
the same problem what about change it
back in my intellij
like here and i pressed
save
i go back again
try again
refresh and there you go devcon is
awesome so now we have the changes so it
kind of like you keep on doing that and
it keeps on um
it will keep on working exactly um
the same way
okay perfect so let's go back to our
intellij and we're gonna
open so so so this was the part where
you see
there is actually
zero configurations at this time in my
application props this is just the
default application that i just created
with the greeting resource now what i
can also do is i can also if you were if
you wanted to do um
testing like for example
um
you like test driven development you
could run your you could start running
your tests as well so here
i just press r
and here it says hey you have a greeting
resource test and it expected hello rest
easy but by the way your test is failing
so i can actually start to code on the
fly
and say hey it wanted to be hello rest
easy so let's just take that that's a
bit of cheating but here you know you
can cheat a bit um and here i save it
and you can see now my chest is passing
so i can see i can actually work live do
my unit test change my unit test save
them and they're doing that imagine that
if you were doing that
without this kind of a functionality
you're here just can start creating new
methods and functions um for your
application
and and
do the proper kind of test driven
development if you wanted to do that so
it's it's pretty awesome uh that you can
you can do that
so great way to get started as well so
now let's let's take a bit more look
into some of the other things as well so
here what i'll do now is so so we've
seen live coding how life coding works
uh we've seen how
um
how we are doing test driven development
that's that's a great feature that you
could do in your dev mode we are in
quark is devmoon
um what about if i wanted to add let's
say um extension an extension a quarkus
extension
um is used that
for example camel is an extension
uh you know database access will be an
extension so there's a bunch of
extensions
that you could basically use uh uh
with quarkus so when i do quarkus
extension list it gives me
uh the list of extensions uh that are
currently out there and there's a bunch
of them so that remember we saw them on
code dot quarkx dot um io as well so now
let's just say that i want to add
quartus extension
uh which one was it uh let's add
hibernate
um so i add hibernate or panache
i will add hibernate validator and then
i want a jdbc
postgres sql database so one thing i
just want to make sure that there is no
postgres sql database
in my
system at the moment let's just stop
that just to make you make sure of that
and you'll be using oh why why is he
stopping the postgres sql database while
he's adding it over here so i'll tell
you why so
so i add this extension over here
um
and of course i'm in the wrong directory
some stuff
um now i'm in the project and of course
i i added this here so now if i go back
to my
to my browser
um
and hit the local host
and go on my dev ui
voila i see data sources
i see hibernate or m there is no
persistent units no entities there no
named queries but hey there's data
sources and why does it have data source
and it already has a default data source
so what is that
that default data source is
the test containers working by default
in action in this in the system let's
take a look at that so
when i go back to my
local host here you will see that
it started
to
initialize step services manage database
and that is basically creating
um
the the container in the back end so if
i went in and the blocker yes
i would see
that there is
um a test container that is running
right now
in the back end
postgres sql here
for my application so this is awesome
like i don't really need to we need to
worry about this every time my
application will start
in dev mode it will automatically
just
just do that as well
so
so that's
that's awesome i can i can actually do
that
um let's
take a look at application properties
there's nothing in the properties and
you know my
my databases
is just running uh by default which you
can see over here if i go back
um now and try to create let's just try
to create a new entity i create a to-do
um entity here
um
and what i'll say is that it's an entity
so similar
to what you might be
um
familiar with
okay
let's see
my imports
somehow seems like maven hasn't picked
up
let's see if that works
yeah there you go
uh extends pinash entity now there's
panash entity and panache entity base
minash entity base gives you uh so
panache is a is a framework which is
which is quite cool which gives you
these uh possibilities to
uh to work with these um you know you
could use your active repository pattern
if you wanted to you can statically call
the methods but it's an awesome tool for
for running uh with your hibernate
applications and kind of takes care of
all this glue code that you would
usually need to write
so in in my case here let's say i take
my to do application
um to do
pojo here that i just created and i'm
gonna just maybe create some uh you know
simple
uh let's just say my to-do i have string
title
uh i want to make sure that this title
is
not blank since it's the main title and
i also want to make sure that this
column is
unique right so give it a
um a property which is unique
e equals to true right so i have that
then of course i want to add
maybe an order
uh to this
now order is is a fun thing because
order
um
is also uh something that is in the
database so the database
um
we can we can choose a different name
and you just say hey our column will be
called ordering instead
and then of course
i choose completed
whether my task is completed or not
and then maybe
so here i will save this and what about
if we actually add some helper functions
just to add some static
uh helper functions as well
um
that could be our to-do's
and we should find
it
so get all the ones that are completed
and here
since it extends panache entity it can
actually
uh
directly call some of these
methods so here we return
the list of completed
items right so i'm just going to cheat a
bit here
and we're saying say find
not completed
and we call it
false just for the final thing
right we can also do something like um
maybe delete some of them
again because
we have
we are extending the panache entity we
have these helper functions
so this is a simple entity that we just
create right just out of the box simple
pojo now what happens let's let's go and
see
what's happening on our
on our browser here
so i'll go back i'll say hey hit my url
again
and i should see
automatically that there is now entities
there is one entity called to do
there is some persistent units so create
and drop scripts are automatically
created
um and then you know no named queries
but then again i can also go into the
database and here you can see that it's
connected to my local you know container
database with some default password name
and users and some properties as well
another cool thing is that i can
actually copy these you know
directly into my application or
properties as test and production
profiles as well which we will
which we'll take a look uh hopefully
later
as well so i got a multiple bunch of
options here um
that i could use just because i added a
new extension
so what about
what about let's say that
we go ahead
um and we add a simple uh rest end point
um and and see how how that's gonna work
as well so let's do that let's just go
back to
um
intellij and we're gonna create a new
um a new java class
um
and we're gonna set it to
resource
and this of course in this case what
we're doing with to do resource is we're
making sure that it's our endpoint that
is going to serve our rest and we're
using rest easy and we're going to use
jax rs as well so that's going to help
us to um to to
take our api out so here we go
jax rs
and we're going to say api
and slash
api and then of course we can say add
consumes
type
dot
application json just making sure
that all of this does that we could also
do this on each
uh each of the
functions but you know just making it
easier over here so what i'm going to do
now is of course i'm going to cheat a
bit
i'm going to just copy some code
long code here in respect of time
and go through that so
so here you'll see
that
what i've done is i've added a couple of
things
um
and
i've added a get all method
uh which is using the sort
coming out of panache
and it's going to sort based on the
order of the tasks uh it's going to have
a function called get one
we're doing a create so we're doing a
valid to-do item to get the actual
to-do item in json and all we do is item
dot persist and it's going to save it
back into the database so now if i go
back to my endpoints here
and i i say
let's go back to our endpoints
and i say
slash api
whoa something is missing what did i
miss so i've missed a library
nice
which library have i missed
we
okay
so
happens right
so let's just add that library extension
add
and since it i know this error it says
util.area list
um is um
so java.tutorial.list
with media to application json that was
the error i'm going to add an extension
called rest easy json b and that's the
one that basically
uh will help me parse this um
so i do that
and quarkx does that and here you can
see that i got a lot of errors doing
that but then again i um
i will go back to my browser
and i'm gonna click
api
and whoa i get another error do i let's
see
so it doesn't
it doesn't like
message body writer
okay did i miss
let's try this again
and
okay
so here we go here we have uh the slash
api
and we can see the end point that it
returns nothing
so what if um what if i did something
like
created
let's go back
and
let's go back to our intellij
and if i created uh an
import.sql file
let's do that
file
and here i'm just gonna
drag
some of the uh some of the things that i
that i want in like by default in my
testing
i do that
and i refresh my browser
let's do that
and i can see whoa i have all the
different
lists here that i added all the tasks
are coming in json now so this is great
now i have the different
you can see how life going is working i
can do all of this
on the fly
and
in making all the changes as i go along
one thing that we that we want to do now
is also look at
remote depth so you can do all of this
but then you can also do this remotely
in in kubernetes since it's a kubernetes
native stack right what i've done i've
cheated a little bit here i've already
deployed my quark is sorry my postgres
database
um
and um i've um it's it's in here
what i want to do now is deploy my
quarkus application as well so i could
deploy a native application by saying
minus p native or i could also deploy
um you know a jvm application at this
point from a developer productivity
point of view it doesn't it doesn't
really matter a lot but what of course
we we kind of uh need to do is we need
to
give some properties to it right so we
need to set up some properties and say
hey
this database service is called postgres
database uh you need to hit that one uh
with the right password and log in
because this is no longer
about the development environment this
is now
going into production so let's let's go
ahead and do that too so if i look at my
application.props
which is kind of pre-loaded i'm doing a
drop-in create
this is kind of like a staging
environment so we can do that
you want to see the sql
we want to see the rest in crud etc
and and all of those things we want to
see as well one thing i also want to do
is
basically
drag some of the
uh you know my ui
as well so let me extra files that i
copied which is a java
script and some index to do html and all
of that so awesome so there is
there is my front end loaded as well so
we did to the api parts now we also do
this so so now let's uh
close our
dev session here
and basically
let's just uh kind of
deploy
and deploy our application so mvn
i'm gonna
say deploy
kubernetes deploy true
but before we do that and before i
forget that
what we want to do is we want to add the
open shift extension because we're going
to use the open shift developer sandbox
so i'm going to add the open shift
extension here
[Music]
unable to list extension unmatched
argument
open shift
okay
yes okay did i miss that before yes i
did i actually missed the outcome
perfect
so
so now i have the extension added and by
doing this now open
whatever my um
open shift environment i'm logged into
this will automatically
um
deploy into that environment and usually
when you're working with
um open shift
uh you can you can kind of say
uh you can see what's you know where you
are so here's my link on the server and
also my my project that i'm currently in
so it's gonna basically just go ahead
and deploy my application in there so
what i'm going to do now is
i'm going to deploy my application
into
into openshift so let's just go ahead
and do that
simple mvn clean package
kubernetes deploy true means that
deployed to kubernetes open shift is a
kubernetes distribution with a lot more
other value added in icd's
and then of course skip tests
we only have a hello world test so we
can skip it let's do that
um
so now it's going to start
basically
uh create a build in openshift so let me
just um
yeah so here it's creating if i go in my
target directory here i will see that
you know it has started creating some
kubernetes manifest files uh you know
from my build
so it understand exactly what it wants
to do it knows what the you know what
kind of image you want to use
all of those things it already knows and
it's going to start deploying and
creating a build which is an s2i build
on top of the openshift environment so
let's go ahead
and take a look at the openshift
environment right so that'll be nice not
this one
so here's my shift environment
um if i go in my builds i can see that
d3 for example
is being built and the build is running
and you can see it's being running there
as well but i can also see that you know
it's receiving
uh the standard um input here
it's copying all the stuff going around
the environment i haven't given any
specific environment any specific
metrics etc
you can observe um your application here
as well and then of course we're in the
topology view where we have our
uh postgres uh database as well so
quickly let's go back
to our intelligent environment and here
you'll see that hey it's copying a lot
of stuff it's pushing the image to the
registry push was successful
it's deploying to the openshift server
and then it says hey i did it
and because i have set the exposed route
to true
it is actually deploying that entire
thing
and then exposing a route to as well
on this as well so let's go back to our
openshift environment and see how that's
looking so here we can see
d3 is deployed if i go in my logs i see
hey the application is deployed it was
pretty fast it started in less than
three seconds you know creating
container and everything
with all the different things in there
and guess what it also has my
application so if i go here i can see my
my application if i go on the dev ui
it's not going to work because dev ui
it treats it as a production environment
right now uh it's not gonna it's not
gonna work i could also go and say to do
dot html
and here oops
i will have
my to-do application as well where i can
see what's going on
if i go to my api
i will again see
my api as well
which has no data at this time for
example
um so we can go back
to tutor.html and say learn
for this
that's my new task so it will just add
this there for example so stuff like
that so it's awesome it's my application
is deployed uh it's working it looks
great but what if uh what if i actually
wanted to
you know do some remote development
which means i want to make changes
remotely so in in respect of time which
i believe i don't have a lot left
so being quick here um i'm gonna let's
go back and do some
some more settings here
and of course i'm copying here just to
just to make it even more enticing
um i said that hey i won't i don't want
my dev services enabled but i do want
you to say i
do want you to launch quark is in dev
mode which means that it's going to add
all the easiness for me to work remotely
from this machine directly into my
kubernetes environment which is uh which
is also pretty awesome and i'm also
telling it that this is my
this is my application which actually is
not so let's change that
um
oops
copy
easy copy please
nope
c
and control
so here i have my
my route which is my applications route
so it knows that this is where it needs
to listen to
so i've done that i've made those
configuration changes same thing now
what i want to do is i want to say
quarkus
and i want to say remote dev so now it's
not just corki's dev mode locally it's
remote dev which is the outer loop which
is on kubernetes so i do that
to the remote server and if i make any
changes like let's say if we were
uh going back
let's do this
if we were
going to a browser again
and i said open this app i can see this
page right now right so so this is the
default page what if uh what if i went
back
and changed this page what if i just
removed index.html
you will see
that as soon as i hit this
it is going to try to
change that
and
it didn't okay
anyways so if i hit hello here
it does that too okay perfect it's going
to try to hit that
so index.html comes there but what i'll
do is i'm going to rename
my to do html to be the main
index page here awesome
and now when i hit the index page
it's going to basically
send that out
to the application and here you can see
that it actually
will reload let's just do that
oops
here you'll see that it actually reloads
that entire page if i hit that again now
my index page is actually on the
to-do.html
let's go back let's do something more
interesting if i go on my resource
and here i say
perhaps what i'll do is that
i remove this function
completely
um
and then if i go back
to my browser
set up this
run again
you will able to see that
over here it has sent a new quarkus
runnable jar
into my container very quickly and in my
browser my application is loaded so if i
try to say
learn
something new
it doesn't really do anything for me
because guess what there is no create
function
anymore
so how about we recreate that create
function
uh save
save it again so here i have my create
function again and i'm going to save it
and i'm going to go back to my browser
again
and here
if you go back
and see an intellij as well that
it has actually
sent all those details there which means
that if i
today
that will go in and now i have something
that is that is working i can say is
you should start the quarkus project on
github that's done visit quarkus website
now get all the active projects so you
can see all of that is working so that's
that's a little bit of prelude into the
different features with with quarkus
with dev services etc so let's just go
back to our
presentation
and
let's
let's let's talk about that
to finish it out so what we've seen so
far is that you can
you can easily have the different
configurations you know simplified
something that i did not show though but
like in in respect of time but happy to
happy to talk about it later and
is where you can actually copy your
configurations through the dev services
console as well um so so this the dev
services ui in the dev mode gives you
all the different possibilities and
configurations that you can copy off as
well if you did not know them for
example to good productivity features
there and the configuration as you saw
is extremely minimal uh you get the
reverse stack trace too
um you get all the different extension
views in your dev services ui uh
developer ui you you get your you know
test containers integrated by default so
if i was to add any other database um
for example mongodb or
if i was working with kafka streams all
of these will also be easily used or if
i was using something like the key clock
project
that will also get loaded and easily
doable uh through the dev service as
well
awesome developer ui
continuous testing we also saw that
easily able to test applications
you know if you're going to going
towards tdd does some great work remote
dev with kubernetes like we just saw it
right now with some basic functions but
you know you can do like pure live
coding uh with that as well and then of
course you can deploy microservices or
functions onto uh onto kubernetes as
well so that was a that was a that was a
small uh demo for you to kind of get
inspired and hopefully you will like it
one of the other things that corkus also
does it it has a reactive core and
that's why it is so performant too so
which means that you can basically write
endpoints with reactive and non-reactive
code at the same time and and quarkus
understands it so you don't need to spin
up different projects to do it in your
same
you know by domain whatever you know
distributions you have in your
application you can easily choose to
do reactive i
possibly recommend it that way but at
the same time if you wanted to mix and
match in one endpoint you know go ahead
you can do that too because quark is is
reactive in its core
lots of frameworks 300 plus extensions
today whether you're using you know
kubernetes extensions key cloak
you know jager um camel all of those
extensions are out there for you to use
and if you wanted to write your own
extension you can do that too with cork
us as well so to end the session
how do you get started i use the
developer sandbox so you have the link
there
you can sign up for
a free open shift developer sandbox
which runs for about 14 days you can
deploy applications to it and you know
kind of play around with how that works
uh you'll get more uh of this on quark
star io
i've also attached the source code for
the demo app here and there's a bunch of
other things that you know you can also
look at for example the idc validation
report that talks about the quarkus
performance that we the numbers we saw
for example
so in the end again
thank you very much
for listening
and hope you liked the talk and if you
did please
give it a thumbs up and
looking forward to speaking to you again
on the channels
cheers